the protests started in Australia and as
the day moved westwards other countries
followed Thailand for a dying on the
streets of Bangkok another in Delhi
India it's pretty simple we want
everyone around us the government the
people to realize and acknowledge the
fact that right now we have a climate
emergency and to treat it the same way
some environmentalists can't keep doing
their wood walk separately everybody in
society needs to pick up their socks and
just start doing the work teenager Greta
tunberg started skipping school on
Fridays a year and a half ago to protest
against climate change
outside Sweden's Parliament she's
inspired a worldwide movement of young
people and parents worried for the
future of the planet
in Frankfurt Germany climate strikers
took aim at Black Friday sales in a city
shopping mall for these people
consumerism is part of the problem such
disruption is a risky strategy though
it's inevitably alienate some people but
the students I spoke to at the london
demonstration said some of this is
necessary the student movement gets
criticized for being disruptive you
should be in school
I think people have big opinions about
it and I think we like a lot of people
do like a lot of disruption but I think
it's important otherwise people won't
listen and they won't and I realize so
there needs to be some this is a global
movement but each country has its own
domestic dynamics the UK is in an
election season with a country going to
the polls on December the 12th and the
climate strike was here are hoping that
their chars their message can put
pressure on the politicians to increase
their climate credentials greenhouse gas
levels are still breaking record highs
global temperatures are already 1.1
degree hotter than before the Industrial
Revolution and still rising the European
Parliament has just declared a climate
emergency in Madrid preparations are
finishing up for next week's UN climate
change conference many governments have
already agreed to a carbon neutral world
by 2050 and limiting temperature rises
to 1.5 Celsius these young people
expects global leaders to honor that
commitment is their future at stake
Rory challon's how 2-0 London